you may recall the 2000 and I believe
12th prosecution of Senator Ted Stevens
from Alaska the dog team doj prosecutors
in that case cheated their way through
that case it only came to light because
of a whistleblower uh and not one of
them received any meaningful uh not only
not punishment but any any meaningful
career consequences so doj is an
organization that is just absolutely
rotten when it comes to keeping its own
house in order and holding its own
members to the same standard as the rest
of us and the FBI as a component of the
Department of Justice uh I would say
reflects uh that cultural uh milieu that
cultural mindset of of of lack of
accountability and double standards